when I'm writing it's about the page  it's not about the movie it's not about  Cinema or anything it's about the  literature of me putting my pen to paper  and and writing a good page and making  it work completely as a a literature uh  document on itself that's my first  artistic contribution and  [Applause]  um  and if I do my job right by the end of  the script  I should be having the thought you know  if I were to just publish this now and  not make it I'm done I've done it I  could actually be okay with just saying  that that's it and then that that can  stand and whoever wants to read it we  will read it and that's and I'm done now  it's mine to f up if I go forward with  it now I always go forward with it but I  actually think you should I for where  I'm coming from I want to love that  script so much that I I'm tempted to  stop I'm tempted to call myself a winner  right then and there